let's learn to multiply
m u l
t i p l
y
and the best way i think to do anything
is just to actually do some examples and
then talk through the examples and try
to figure out what they mean
my first example i have two
times
three
by now you probably know what two plus
three is
two plus three
that's equal to five and if you need a
bit of a review you could think of if i
had two
i don't know two magenta that this color
cherries and i wanted to add to it
uh
three
blueberries how many total pieces of
fruit do i now have and you'd say oh one
two three four five or likewise if i had
our number line
and if
let me see
you probably don't need this review but
it never hurts never hurts to reinforce
the concept
and if this is
if you're sitting
2 to the right of 0 and in general when
we go positive we go to the right
and if you were to add 3 to it you would
move 3 spaces to the right so if i said
you know if
if i just moved over three to the right
where do i end up one
two
three i end up at five so either way you
understand that two plus three is equal
to five so what is two times three
an easy way to think about
multiplication or or timesing something
is it's just a it's just a simple way of
doing addition over and over again so
what this means is and it's a little
tricky
you're not going to add two to three
you're going to add and there's actually
two ways to think about it you're going
to add two to itself
three times what does that mean what
means you're going to say 2
plus 2
plus
2.
now where did the three go well how many
how many twos do we have here
let's see i have
this is a one two i have two twos i have
three twos i'm counting the numbers here
the same way that i counted blueberries
up here i had one two three blueberries
i have one two three two so this three
tells me how many twos
i'm going to have
so what's two times three well i took
two and i i added it to itself three
times so two plus two is four
four plus two is equal to
six
now that's only one way to think about
it the other way we could have thought
about this
is we could have said instead of having
two added to itself three times
we could have added three to itself two
times and i know it's maybe becoming a
little bit confusing but the more
practice you do it'll make a little
sense
so this statement up here let me rewrite
it
two times
three
it could also be rewritten as
three two times so three
plus
three
and once again you're like where did
this two go where did you know i had two
times three you know and whenever you do
addition you see i have two
uh i don't know what these well i said
cherries but they could be raspberries
or anything and then i you know i had
two things i had three things and and
the two and the three never disappear
and i add them together i get five
but here i'm saying that two times three
is the same thing as three plus three
where did the two go two in this case in
this scenario is telling me how many
times i'm going to add 3 to itself and
once but what's interesting is
regardless of which
way i interpret 2 times 3 i can
interpret it as 2 plus 2 plus 2 or
adding 2 to itself
three times i can interpret it that way
or i can interpret it as adding three to
itself two times
but notice i get the same answer what's
three plus three
that is also equal to 6. and this is
probably the first time in mathematics
you'll encounter something very neat
that sometimes regardless of the path
you take as long as you take a correct
path you get the same answer so two
people can kind of visualize it as long
as they're visualizing it correctly two
different problems but they come up with
the same
solution and so you're probably saying
sal you know when when is this when is
this multiplication thing even useful
and this is where it's useful sometimes
it simplifies counting
so let's say i have
i have a
a
well let's let's stick with our our our
fruit analogy
an analogy is just when you kind of use
something as as an egg well i won't go
too much into it but our fruit example
let's say i had lemons let me draw a
bunch of lemons so i'll draw them in
rows of three so i have one
two
three
well i'm not going to count them because
that'll give our answer away
just drawing a bunch of lemons
now you could if i said
you tell me how many lemons there are
here and if you if i did that you would
proceed to just count all of the lemons
and it wouldn't take you too long to say
that oh you know there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 lemons so i actually already
gave you the answer we know that there
are 12 lemons there
but there's an easier way and a faster
way to count the number of lemons
notice how many lemons are in each row
and a row is kind of a
the side to side
lemons i think you know what a row is
i don't want to talk down do you
so how many lemons are there in a row
well there are three lemons in a row
and now let me ask you another question
how many rows are there
how many rows
well that this was one row then this is
the second row
this is the third row
and this is the fourth row
so an easy way to count it as i say i
have three lemons per row and i have
four of them so let's say i have three
lemons per row
and i hope i'm not confusing you but i
think you'll enjoy this
and then i have four rows so i have four
times three lemons
four
times three lemons and that should be
equal to the number of lemons i have
12. and just to make that gel with what
i just did with the addition let's think
about this four times three
literally when you and you know when you
actually say out the word four times
three i visualize
this i visualize four times three so
three
four times three plus three plus three
and if we did that we get three plus
three is six
six plus three is nine
nine plus three is twelve and we learned
in in up here at this part of the video
we learned that this same
multiplication
could also be interpreted as
three times four you can switch the
order and this is one of the the useful
and interesting actually uh
kind of properties of of multiplication
but this could also be written as four
three times
four
plus four plus four you add four to
itself three times four plus four is
eight eight plus four
is
twelve and in in in the u.s we always
say 4 times 3 but you know
i've i've met people and a lot of people
my family they kind of learned in the uh
i guess you could call it the english
system and they'll often they'll often
call this four threes or three fours and
that in some ways is a lot more
intuitive it's not intuitive the first
time you hear it but they'll write this
multiplication problem or they'll say
this multiplication problem and they'll
say what are four threes and when they
say four threes they're literally saying
what are four threes so this is one
three two three's three threes four
threes so what are four threes when you
add them up it's twelve and you could
also say what are three fours so this is
so let me write this down this is
let me do it in a different color that
is four
threes
i mean literally that's four threes if i
told you to say
write down four threes and add them up
that's what that is and that is four
times three or three four times
and this is
let me do that in a in a different color
that is
three
fours
and it could also be written as three
times four and they all equal twelve
and now you're probably saying okay this
is nice it's a cute little trick sal
that you've taught me but
it took you less time to count these
these these lemons than to you know do
this problem and well first of all
that's only right now because you're new
to multiplication but what you'll find
is there are times
there are times and there are actually
many times and i don't want to use the
word times too much in a video on
multiplication
where
each row of lemons instead of having
three maybe they have a hundred lemons
and maybe there's maybe there's you know
a hundred rows and it would take you
forever to count all the lemons and
that's where multiplication comes really
useful although we're not going to learn
right now how to multiply a hundred
times a hundred
now the one thing that i want to get in
this is kind of a trick i remember my
sister just to to try to show how much
smarter she was than me when i was in
kindergarten and she was in third grade
she would say sal what is
three
times one and i would say because my
brain would say oh that's like three
plus one and i would say three plus one
is equal to four and so i say oh you
know three times one that must be four
as well and she'd say no silly it's
three and i was like how can that be how
can it you know how can the three times
some other number still be the same
number and think about what this means
you could view this as three
three ones
and what are three ones that's one one
plus another one plus another one and
that's equal to 3 or you could view this
as 3 one time so what's 3 one time
it's almost silly how easy it is it's
just 3 that's 1 3. you could write this
as 1 3
and that's why anything times one or one
times anything is that anything so in
three times one is three
one time one times three is three and
you know i could say a hundred
times 1 is equal to
i could say that
1 times 39
is equal to 39
and i think you're familiar with numbers
this large by now so that's interesting
now there's one other really interesting
thing about multiplication and that's
when you multiply by zero and i'll start
with the analogy or the example when you
add
three plus zero you've hopefully learned
is three because i'm adding nothing to
the three if i have three apples and i
give you zero more apples you still have
three apples but what is three and i'm
maybe i'm just fixated on the number
three a little bit too much let me
switch what is
four four
times zero
well this is saying
zero four times so what's zero plus zero
plus zero
well that's that's zero
right i have nothing plus nothing plus
nothing plus nothing so i get nothing
another way to think of it i could say
four zero times so how do i write four
zero times well i just don't write
anything right because if i if i write
anything if i write 1 4 then i don't
have no fours i'm talking this is saying
so this is this is 4
let me write this
this is
zeros
but i could also write zero
fours
and what are zero fours well i'll just
write a big blank here there i wrote it
there are no fours here so it's just a
big blank and that's another fun thing
so anything times zero is zero i could
write a huge number you know five
million four hundred ninety three
thousand six hundred and ninety two
times zero
what does that equal that equals zero
and by the way what's this number times
1 well it's that number again and what's
0 times you know
17.
once again
that is 0.
anyway i think i've talked for long
enough see you in the next video